berlin s'est encore pour presque tout le
monde
le mur et la mort de ceux qui ont tenté
de le franchir
d'est en ouest notes oublier que la
partie occidentale de l'ancienne
capitale du reich est aussi l'une des
vitrines de l'économie libérale et du
capitalisme à l'est le centre de berlin
et le kurfürstendamm rappelle certains
quartiers de paris berlin
c'est aussi adossé au mur des îlots
populaire et pauvres qui contraste avec
des quartiers d'affaires créé de toutes
pièces sans que rien dans les ressources
de la ville ne justifie leur présence
berlin c'est essentiellement le point de
réunions de l'est et de l'ouest
politique avec ce mur
omniprésent qui s'ouvrent et se ferment
au gré des rapports entre les blocs avec
la politique à l'est de vibrantes
marquée par la signature des traités de
moscou et de varsovie et la signature
d'un autre traité avec l'allemagne de
l'est
le gouvernement de bonn a permis des
changements sensibles à berlin la
situation du est en net s'est amélioré
après des années de séparation des
familles défiance et des amis ont pu se
retrouver pour les fêtes de fin d'année
mais au delà de ses conséquences
humanitaires du traité entre les deux
allemagnes c'est une tout autre vocation
que semble avoir berlin à l'heure de la
détente en europe
klaus chute ce qui a succédé à vie libre
à la mairie de berlin espère que la
politique à l'est de son pays a permis
d'avoir grâce au traité fondamental un
premier vrai contact avec l'europe de
l'est
il espère aussi que la partie
occidentale de berlin deviendra un des
plus importants lieux de rencontre entre
l'est et l'ouest et que dans le même
temps sa ville sera en mesure de devenir
une grande métropole européenne
le souci de faire de berlin un lieu de
confrontation entre l'est et l'ouest
entre deux types de sociétés et de
régime
c'est surtout celui de la jeunesse
berlinoise progressiste et désireuse de
renouer avec les jeunes de l'autre côté
du mur sans pour autant croire à la
réunification des deux allemagnes plus
l'espoir non non on jamais eu l'idée
d'une allemagne
face de l'est de l'ouest réunis parce
qu'elles n'ont pas l'expérience d'une
histoire laquelle étaient faits par les
parents par exemple à quoi ça se posait
toujours la question pour le jeune
spécial ans hier d'allant pourquoi cette
confrontation
berlin capitale d'une allemagne
réunifiée
c'est là une hypothèse de moins en moins
crédible non seulement pour les jeunes
mais aussi pour la plupart des hommes
politiques allemands
une preuve bonne capitale fédérale que
d'aucuns croyaient provisoire se
développe de manière irréversible
cette petite ville rhénane continue
d'être un gigantesque chantier
et c'est ici dans ces immeubles en
construction que dans quelques mois le
gouvernement allemand réinstallera ses
fonctionnaires